what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we got ourselves yet another trailer
for Spider-Man across the spider verse we're
working on a Creed 3 reaction at it that's
right I'm plugging something coming up this week
guys that's how you YouTube and now John's here
what's up John welcome to a one in the morning
shoot how you doing buddy I am I'm energized I'm
jacked up and ready to Traverse the spider verse
I'm excited I did not actually see the one that
you covered with koi um before this is gonna be
very fresh for me oh good I'm excited for you
me too Swip that like button let's get to it
only Spiderman and things are going great oh yeah
you're supposed to be here
all right whatever whatever
oh man
I am the spot yep it's not funny
don't do that miles is great they're pretty
good that's my little man and a B in Spanish
he's lying to you and I think you know it
spot gonna be like the main village it looks like
it or at least a big Force wanna get out of here
wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best that's a good troop
who's the new guy oh no way spider
[__] oh there's the Iron Spider
the whole thing was his idea what's it I
gotta do to join this spider team you can
I'll take it from here miles
and saved in every world
trolley problem I can't do that I
can do both Spider-Man always always
Uncle Ben most of us wouldn't be
God this looks freaking epic yeah this
isn't what we talked about wow I had no idea
how are you doing everyone holy [__] you're so
Ted's supposed to go nah I'm gonna do my own thing
spider therapy
oh
we're going like 22 Jump Street terrain at
that point oh so much I mean the ending of
22 Jump Street oh wow that was overwhelming I
saw Spider-Man no way home three times in the
theaters I saw into the spider-verse three times
in theaters needless to say I'm a Spider-Man fan
not this guy hates Spider-Man but all about
that morbius train I think this trailer was
beautiful because it provided all the Vivid
wild imaginative fun that I want from this
movie it managed to communicate both emotions
in this trailer where it felt very expressive
and massive like the scales seem so much bigger
yet it still had this very personal Stakes touch
at least what I was picking up on here I'm not
exactly sure what the movie's main inner conflict
is going to be dealing with but from what it
seemed like they were teasing among amidst the
chaos he's torn between a choice where he has to
kind of allow his dad to die you know there are
all these things about letting Uncle Ben die and
it seems like uh you know but part of what the
trajectory has to be is allow Wing Jefferson Davis
to die but and but yet you know he does have that
moment where he's interacting with Miguel O'Hara
saying that you know people keep saying how my
story is supposed to go but I'm gonna I'm gonna
dictate how I'm gonna let it play out and then
they were referencing no way home you know was all
about trying to like control the way events went
down I loved that possibility of him having to
deal with such a personal choice because you got
to keep a person because I don't think the first
movie did so well was allowing yeah you got all
these Spider-Man characters you got all these
references you got all this great animation and
everything but they still managed to be a really
strong Miles Morales story I think that they found
like a good core there which will create some real
tough choices there are parts of this where the
conflict with Miguel O'Hara and Miles Morales some
reminded me of doctor strange and engine how it's
supposed to go down yeah we're dealing with the
interdimensional with this stuff it's not about
you it's about the greater good it's about all the
Multiverse it's not just this universe yeah but
it still looked very very fun because yeah it's
Easter eggs Galore up in here I loved it I thought
that was awesome I had just chills throughout this
looked like rousing yeah no it was like super rich
like it's almost like a dense little short film
in unto itself because like spider-verse has a
wonderfully overwhelming quality about it where
yeah there's so much visual expression but there's
also a ton of emotional expression and this had
both uh flavors kind of an equal measure all the
fun all the you know varying different uh arrays
of Spider-Man that we're gonna see but also it
seems like this will be incredibly difficult in
terms of the personal Journey not only for the
idea that he might have to let Jefferson die in
order to secure the greater good but you know his
entanglement with Gwen and you know her reaching
out across universes to get to him and not wanting
to probably lose that and then coming into what
seemed like a big amount of conflict with not only
Miguel O'Hara but at least a certain amount of
the Spider-Man who are probably on his particular
wavelengths yeah it almost seems like you know
they're gonna take that coming of age even further
and having that you know uh sort of stubbornness
to say no I'm going to dictate how the story ends
I feel like there was a lot of great potential
for growth for miles in that but also a lot of
potential for tragedy and I feel like one thing
Lord and Miller and their you know cohorts are
really good at are giving us things that are
both fun but meaningful and that will kind of
have that weight and have that challenge in it
like what I wasn't expecting was like the spot
in this is like so impish and so kind of whimsical
in his presence and I was coming in thinking like
oh that's going to be the main villain but here
it more looks like an internal conflict between
Miguel and miles and everybody else it seems like
spot probably creates some because he's like an
interdimensional villain yeah and it seems like by
accident he creates a problem sure that they have
to fix because there's something that feels like
really goofy I mean spot so it seems like they're
they're leaning into a comedic side of what
causes this you know Universal scale to deal with
um versus just a massive meaningful menacing
threat you know sure um but I thought it was
great I mean yeah you got you got some great
references here to all the other Spider-Man
and I saw images of the the previous trailer so
it looks like they've done a lot of that here I
really thought that was a spider Punk right on the
guitar I believe so yeah yeah I've been trying to
skim this while John was talking and I'm like
I cannot find that image there's so many images
this will be on every Easter eggs break down like
all 155 Spider-Man and women that appear in this
trailer and yet it was another thing that I sort
of gathered from part of its emotional core was
him having more of a relationship Dynamic with
his mom this time around yeah uh not that she
wasn't important in the first one but so much
of the first one had a father and son tale and
this seems like it'll have a little bit more to do
with his mom but Miguel O'Hara man that he I don't
trust him yeah I know that was the last thing I
was expecting I mean he's come across as you know
like brooding and intense in the previous little
flashes that we've seen in the previous trailer
but here it it does look like he is like going mad
trying to hold this whole operation together and
might be crossing over potentially into extreme
territory that might be you know beyond the pale
of what's truly moral what is you know left up
to that great responsibility you know and Peter
B Parker is back with a baby he's back so many
Peter's B Parker at one of their Con in there guys
what did you think about this trailer I thought it
was awesome yeah I cannot wait for this there's a
theater one oh we're not gonna react to that here
I'm gonna watch the theaters I'll pay someone else
I'll do it I hate Spider-Man I know
all right guys well what did you think
about this trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave
a like and hey while we're here
this hour let's end this with a
Anisa Oliva if I was to travel the Multiverse to
discover a whole bunch of other nieces I will want
to meet all the Anisa variants I'd want to meet
black Anissa oh yeah I want to meet Japanese Nisa
Japanese I wanted to meet Chinese Nisa I would
want to meet South African Nisa I'd want to meet
Tech though you are from Texas I don't want to
meet Utah yeah yeah how different would she be
from Texas Nisa I want to meet New York Nissan
I want to meet Canada nice Canada Nisa I want to
meet uh Bulgarian Nissan yeah Amsterdam Anisa I
want to meet turkey Nissan oh yeah uh Jupiter I
want to meet North Dakota Nissan yeah and I want
them all to come across exactly the same sure I
don't want there to be any discernible differences
here in Nexus being because I'm not racist I want
them all to come across exactly the same yes I
want Chinese Nisa to be speaking Spanish it's just
like ours yeah I'm saying y'all a lot this is the
Texas accent yeah because Nissa I want to travel
the Anisa verse Oh across the Anisa version John
would take them all out on dates dates trying to
find the perfect Anisa to marry oh that's a high
concept movie I found the perfect woman but it's
women but I have I can't decide which variant is
the best it's the best one to be and he's gonna
have to choose between which one of the anisas
all of them I can't shoot how could I possibly
go with Blackness Blackness black nieces for me
it's Anisa from Texas and blackface it's a really
racist thing and for some reason John's really
the Heart Wants What It Wants orbius and blackface